if the fans when they see this film
would take away something what what are
your hopes that they take away from this
film i hope they just uh i hope they
enjoy it as much as they've enjoyed the
other ones i think that's such an
important part of this film a lot of
people try to talk about you know the
themes and
all these things i think like i just
hope that they just have have fun you
know i hope that it
gives them a you know two hours of
two hours of break from the real world
and just like
you know
it's been a long time oh
you look so businessy um i mean don't
let this soup fool you you know i'm
still a rebel oh last friday left work
20 minutes early whoa yeah i know i
don't like to talk about it
your
tell me about the time jump at the end
is it what you expected when you read
the script to see the characters where
they were not necessarily no but i think
um
i think it's nice to
to see that kind of well-rounded ending
and see where they end up it's less
ambiguous and
you kind of can you can kind of gauge an
idea of where it's going and
what happens you know
standing there at the carnival
and seeing noah again after all that
time
i couldn't help but think of one thing
[Music]
no one understands me quite like you do
through all of the shadowy corners of me
that all of this happened
just because of
well
you know it feels like it sets up
another movie i mean most movies kind of
feel like they have that ability at this
point in the perfect world where would
you like to see if there was a fourth
movie it come back in time is it 10
years 20 years later is it kids in the
picture where where's what's the era for
you i think i'd like to see them all in
a nursing home together
yeah that would be cool that would be
quite interesting and then maybe it's
like
it's like the film is like a series of
monologues of them recounting everything
that happened from 20 to
92.
yeah so you think you think l and noah
make it the long the long haul well i'm
not sure if they do or not but that's
what i would
i just think it would be interesting to
see that yeah i mean it's pretty
romantic to think of to see the flick
like that and you guys aged up and to
play those characters would be lovely um
no no we play it when we're 90.
[Music]
in line with the movie tell me a little
bit about a bucket list do you have a
bucket list do you do you do like a
summer bucket list like stuff i want to
do in the summer and who are you with
you with friends family what goes down
you know i don't really have a bucket
list i wouldn't i'm more of a
player as a ladies kind of person um
but i but if if i could see my my ideal
summer would be at home with my uh with
my family and my uh
my mates just sort of uh at the beach
it's very very easy you know
yeah laid back and relaxing yeah exactly